hook up and done though yeah you did
you did like him I remember this hmm I
remember when I saw her naked for the
first time yeah just hear me out I won't
hear you out mm-hmm and I I looked at
her body and I looked up in the sky and
I've verbally said thank you God yeah
that's nice that's the biggest
compliment I could give you baby but you
thought that like you're getting played
right you're like this is a [ __ ] spy
like she's gonna kill me or something
no you know because let me if you'll
believe it or not yeah you know i-i've
been with some attractive women saw you
with a six-foot blonde that's right yeah
come on but what's special about kalila
is is that she you know with with with
white chicks and stuff mm-hmm
you have to get the Korean stuff you
kind of have to hide it kind of ease
them into it or even if they're they
can't get like if you could bring into a
Korean restaurant yeah what is that
yeah yeah like oh it's this nah I'm not
gonna eat that guys are gross this [ __ ]
right it will eat the eyeballs of a
[ __ ] fish if you'll take this
chopsticks up and eat the [ __ ]
eyeballs yeah yeah first before you eat
everything of it yeah she's very Asian
yeah like easy I don't know but I could
take her to like a province mm-hmm right
and we could be in the jungle and we're
fine have you guys gone to the
Philippines oh you have yeah yeah and
she are but his idea of a vacation is
like an all-inclusive five-star hotel
and that's not mine I like the province
I like you know just you want to be a
real experience yeah like I want to be
where my family is I don't want to stay
in a hotel when my family is like let me
tell you guys something [ __ ] rice
patio something right now okay what's
that bro when you think of vacation do
you think of relaxation
mm-hm or do you think of adventure
personally yes I'm a relaxation person
hmm so am i yeah
when I think of vacation I think of not
moving that's how I have the best the
best of vacation that I can think of is
a place called Combe
yeah being in a full-blown two-week coma
yeah if I was in a coma for two weeks
and I woke up I would like what that was
beautiful yeah I'm with you dude I'm
going back next year yeah I love it
right she's Laura Croft that's not true
yeah she's let's go to the tomb what
tomb in the jungle oh so we can die why
don't you just go somewhere that has
your relaxation and then you go yeah but
no [ __ ] I had to go on I have to bring
the pack pack and I have to wake up at
5:00 in the morning and I have to be in
the ocean with the sharks have her to be
happy hell I took him shark diving
without a cage just open in the ocean in
the Philippine he loved it no in Hawaii
foof and he did it Wow are you happy you
did it like afterwards me like this is
awesome or were you like this [ __ ]
song I'm happy I'm still alive with all
my limbs friend yeah yeah okay that's
what I'm happy that shit's not fun
particularly fun when you're done yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah it was
exhilarating that was great I love
eating she went all I'm saying is that
look if you stay in a hotel all day I'm
running into the same people I was
trying to get away from which is like
the [ __ ] you know it I don't like the
feeling I like in a told Koran Waialae a
hotel in Maui the papayas that the
papaya arm sauna you know me I just did
Maui last month would you cast a four
seasons right by the grind away layout
yeah yeah it was amazing though it's
beautiful place [ __ ] beautiful right
did you go to the steam room are you a
spa guy I went three times nine days no
did did Christine make you do any
adventures no of course not she didn't
go to high well we are aligned with
vacation approach it's in other words
like we're both like let's not move I
mean that's so but you knew this about
me I know you're right tinder pictures
were all in the ocean I am a diver I
Tsukuba dive I free diver swimmer for 15
years you know what you got bro I know
my god I
you didn't deviate from your
Janell self i didn't deviate either I've
always been no water breathing do with
the eyes
[Music]